we're now in May two thousand eighteen
and it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'm gonna talk about what
went on in April and what we've got
coming up in the month of May
I always like to begin by highlighting
three big things so without any further
ado here they are big thing number one
podcasting I'm going to be taking my
videos and converting them into podcasts
as people have been asking for a long
time for me to do once I reach the next
level of support on patreon so I'll talk
about that in the April section and big
thing number two I've now passed today
the 50,000 subscriber mark on YouTube in
the main channel so I'm planning on
having a little celebration about that
coming up this weekend online where I'll
you know raise a glass and and have
people participate with me in about an
hour so of chatting back and forth
through video conferencing and then the
third thing big thing number three is
we've started doing something new with
the MKE stoic fellowship stoic walk and
talks on Saturdays I'm gonna be hosting
the second of these coming up this
Saturday Saturday morning here in
Milwaukee alright so let's talk about
April now there's a lot of other things
to talk about but I'm going to mention
just at the beginning because people
were a bit concerned I am over whatever
sickness it was that I had in the
earlier months that was taking a lot out
of my energy level and I've been hitting
the gym anywhere from three to five
times a week
feeling better not actually losing any
weight in a reliable way but certainly
losing a lot of fat and adding muscle
and feeling feeling better and I'm
actually at the point now where I'm
enjoying and looking forward to going to
work out rather than seeing it
a chore that I've scheduled for myself
as an appointment well maybe I'll shoot
a video about that or talk about that in
a blog post alright let's talk about
events we we had our normal online
events an AMA session philosophy pop-ups
you can see the videos for those linked
to below we of course did our philosophy
chat for my patreon supporters you know
that's one of the perks that it offered
to them and we had our MKE
face to face stoic fellowship meeting
we're almost done with Senecas letters
at this point and we discussed a lot of
important business and I did one face to
face lecture the one on an L Sprague to
camp and Fletcher Pratt's complete
enchanter series in the worlds of
speculative fiction talk series which is
now well into its third year I do want
to mention something about the patreon
podcasting thing so people have been
asking me for a long time
hey would you start converting some of
your videos into mp3s so I can listen to
them on the go you know watch instead of
watching them listen to them as I'm you
know commuting biking cooking whatever a
lot of people don't want to use
streaming service which makes total
sense so I've been giving a lot of
thought to this and I said well if I'm
gonna do it I want to do it right I want
to take the older videos and you know
boost the sound quality maybe put an
intro and an outro and and you know do
the whole podcasting thing the way it's
supposed to be done so that's gonna take
some some extra time so I put that in
there in patreon when I reach the next
level of monthly support on patreon I've
committed to starting to do those
podcasts anywhere from 10 to to 12 maybe
if I get really ambitious 15 of them a
month so if you want to see those you
know that start you might want to start
contributing if you're if you're already
contributing thanks very much for that
support looking forward to doing this
but it is it is a lot of work so I
mentioned that in the
Apryl part because I created that that
new sort of appeal in in April it did a
lot of going on on other people's shows
as a guest doing interviews you know
podcasts radio shows this last month
some of them that are linked to below
here in the video description my own
worst enemy we did almost a two-hour
discussion about anger and what
philosophical resources can do to help
us with that I was also on the stoic
solution podcast talking about this
notion of in accordance with nature and
what it means for the Stoics I went on
the image for hire local radio show here
with the skräuss talking about a whole
bunch of different issues and then I
went on a conservative hosts show
Benjamin Boyce and I think surprised him
a little bit on some of the points some
of his viewers were not entirely happy
with the things that I had to say but
you know that's that's that's the shakes
right so you can see links to all of
those below I did get a good bit of
popular writing done this month I'm very
happy about that
a rexis Deanna at TK my main blog I've
now got it really up and running again
something I haven't had consistently for
for several years I did some blogging in
the half-hour Haegele blog and I'll be
doing more of that this month and I did
get the heavy metal philosopher going
again as well I've been teaching an
online class world views and values for
four Marist College by the way if you're
interested in taking a similar class but
not for credit you can find that link to
below here as well I was asked by the
Marquette philosophy department to
consider teaching for the next semester
and I agreed so I'm scheduled for
teaching two sections of their new class
I forget exactly what it's called but
it's something like an intro to
philosophy class with a few other things
added into it that a lot of tutorial
sessions
not surprisingly as semester winds down
but I also have my regular clients did
some philosophical counseling some
coaching doing some consulting work so a
lot of a lot of interesting side
projects I didn't get a lot of academic
writing done and I didn't get as much
work on the book projects as I would
have preferred but you know it was kind
of a busy month and I did manage to get
a good bit of work done on videos I
finally got my six half-hour Hegel's
done for the month we wrapped up the
Cicero on duties core concepts I did a
whole series of core concept videos on
Rene Descartes discourse on method you
can see a blog post about that in our
exes do you know a TK of course there's
the event video from the Sci Fi event
the AMA video a philosophy pop-up on
philosophy and anger and I did quite a
few additional Q&A videos you know these
common answers answers to common
questions and I did another book review
which I'm quite happy about what have we
got coming up in May a lot of events
many of which are online so wherever you
happen to be you can participate in them
the first event is actually over with
but that was a face to face event here
in the Milwaukee area in my philosophers
in the midst of history I did my my
lecture on st. Augustine and the fall of
the Roman Empire and and what was going
on within the church at the time I did
that on the first so you know I didn't
really have the time to do this video to
talk about that beforehand we've got two
things coming up this Saturday May 5th
at 9:00 a.m. locally here in Milwaukee
we are doing our second stoic walk and
talk at Lake Park in Milwaukee we're
gonna walk about maybe one and a half
miles and chat about about stoicism will
have a passage that will you know I'll
read first and then we'll walk around
and people can ask me whatever they like
this is open to anybody
anybody in the area who wants to
participate in it normally one of the
other members of the stoic fellowship is
leading it which I'm very happy about
but he has to be out of town this
weekend so if you if you show up to this
one you get me as the host instead which
may be you know an attraction for some
people maybe not for others so that is
at 9 a.m. at Lake Park here in Milwaukee
then at 2 p.m. we are going to hold an
online event special party now of course
you know I'll be having a beer on my end
you can have whatever you want to have
on your end and we'll have a toast and
raise a glass celebrating reaching the
50 thousand subscribers mark in in
YouTube so kind of a big thing you'll
see the link to that below as well and
you can find the event listed on my
Facebook page and on the reason I own a
website on the 9th which is a Wednesday
at 5:00 p.m. Central Time all these
online events are in Central Time half
hour Hagel public Q&A and discussion
session if you've got questions about
Hagel about German idealism about any of
those sorts of things show up it's for
everybody you don't have to be a patreon
supporter to participate in that we do
also have another one especially for
patreon supporters that's that's later
on on the 10th which is a Thursday at 7
p.m. here locally at the Brookfield
Public Library we continue with our
worlds of speculative fiction series
this time talking about Andre Norton's
which world series and we're going to
look at the first three volumes because
she wrote a lot of books in that series
really wonderful text by by very
interesting author on the 12th which is
that Saturday 12 p.m. Central Time I
will be having my AMA that's asking me
anything session so you got any
questions for me
you got questions about philosophy in
general show up to that for an hour
usually an hour and a half I'm there
answering them in the order that I see
them sometimes I miss some of them and
towards the end you want to get yours in
early because towards the end we get
overwhelmed with questions finally on
the 19th another Saturday 2:00 p.m. we
have a philosophy chat session just from
my patreon supporters and that's that's
videoconferencing so I you know you see
me in real time I can see you if you if
you want to show yourself and we chat
about whatever these patreon supporters
want to discuss it's one of the perks
for people belonging to that so that's a
natural segue into once again talking
about the podcasting thing I am hoping
that I'm going to reach the next level
of support on patreon before the end of
the month and if I do then you're gonna
see some podcasts coming out and I'll be
taking videos that I've shot probably
start with some of the older ones and
you know boost the sound quality take
out anything that that you know seems to
be dead air maybe add some some cool you
know images or things like that you know
for the thumbnail and some good outro
and intro stuff as well so that's
something that hopefully you can look
forward to if we get enough new support
coming in gonna continue on the writing
I'm gonna hammer away at some of the
book projects that I've got on going get
a continue writing in a rexis T&O ad 2k
my main blog in half our Hegel and heavy
metal philosopher I also have a piece
coming out this Saturday in stoicism
today about the workshop that I did at
stoic on 2017 so you might take a look
for that I'm going to be also doing some
guest posting in common sense ethics
policy of truth and hopefully if I get
it done in the partially examined wife
it's about time that I started follow
threw on some of these invitations that
I get to do guest writing the mayor's
class is wrapping up they they actually
take their final exam next week I'm
starting to write syllabi for the
Marquette class and of course I'm doing
a lot of tutorial work you know
philosophical counseling consulting
if you're interested in those services
by the way go to reason i/o comm or you
can email me directly and we'll start
the ball rolling on that if you want to
bring in a philosopher to help you out
with some some issues videos I'm going
to be of course doing you know videos
from the events so you know if you
missed the AMA or or you miss Lee the
philosophy pop up or you know you can't
make it to the talks that I'm doing here
locally you'll be able to see them in
the the video channel I've got my normal
quota of six half hour Hagel videos to
do this month we're in the middle of the
absolute freedom and terror section very
exciting I think a lot of other people
will be quite excited to know that now
that that dick heart business is done
I'm going to be doing some new core
concept videos that people have been
waiting for for quite a while the
introduction to heidegger's being and
time got a few book reviews that i that
i want to get caught up on i'm gonna do
some more Q&A videos as well and i've
got another interview in the ideas that
matter sequence coming out and i'm
hoping to do some more interviews later
this this month as well with some people
who are here locally so that's
everything that's going on in May a lot
of stuff on the docket to get cracking
on hope you have a great month and
hopefully I'll see you at some of these
events and remember if you if you want
to see those podcasts coming forth
become a patreon supporter there's a lot
of cool perks that come with it and it's
a great way to to you know be involved
and to give something back and to help
me continue doing the work that I
you here bringing philosophy to a
worldwide audience
you